[Music]
Welcome back to Harbor Unbox. Today I am
finally getting to the Radeon RX 6950 XT
and apologies for the delay, but we did
feel it was bit more important to check
out FSR 2.0. So that's why we delayed
this content. Anyway, the time has come
to check out the refreshed 6T950 XT. So
let's get into it. Like the 6650 XT and
6750 XT, the 6T950 XT is based on the
same die as the original model. So in
this case, the Na'vi 21-based 6TN00 XT.
The core count is exactly the same. The
only changes affect core clock
frequency, which has been boosted by 3%
and then the memory bandwidth has also
been increased this time by 13% thanks
to the use of 18 Gbits pers GDDR6
memory.
So based on that, we're expecting the
typical performance gains over the 6TN00
XT to be in the vicinity of 5 to 10%.
Not exactly exciting, but it should help
AMD and their flagship Halo product type
battle with Nvidia.
As many of you know, I don't really care
much for these Halo products. They're a
bit silly in my opinion, or in the case
of the RTX 3090 Ti, they're very silly
given the price tag. So, the fact that
AMD has increased the MSRP from $1,000
to $1,100 doesn't really bother me. I
was much more concerned with the price
increases for the 6650 XT and 6750 XT,
for example. Having said all of that, in
the current market, the 6900 XT is not
nearly as silly as it would have been
had MSRPs actually been a thing. As it
stands, the 6900 XT and 6800 XT are
almost within the same price range. And
although the new 6950 XT is likely going
to be worse value, it's not going to be
that much worse and should be worlds
better than Nvidia's high-end options.
So, when it comes to Halo type products,
the 6950 XT might actually end up being
okay given the current market
conditions, which is a bit of an odd
thing, but that could very well end up
being the case. Now, for testing, all
AMD and Nvidia GPUs have been tested at
the official clock specification, so no
factory overclocking here. And all data
in this video is fresh and was gathered
in the past week or so using the Ryzen 7
5800X 3D with 32 GB of dual rank dual
channel DDR4 3200 CL14 memory on the
ASUS ROG Crosshair 8 Extreme motherboard
using the latest BIOS supporting a JSA
127 micro code. In total, I've tested 11
games at 1080p, 1440p, and 4K. Though
due to the somewhat boring nature of the
data, I'm only going to look at the data
for five games individually before
getting into the 11 game average results
and of course our cost per frame
analysis. All graphs though will be made
available to float plane and Patreon
members. Okay, let's get into the data.
Starting with Rainbow 6 extraction, we
find the 6T950 XT chart topping at 1080p
with 309 FPS. And that's a 10% increase
over the sixtyn00 XT, which is about
what we're expecting to see. That
allowed it to just nudge ahead of the
much more expensive RTX3090 Ti at this
lower resolution. And it's an 11% boost
over the RTX3080 Ti, a GeForce GPU
that's still more expensive than the
6T950 XT. Jumping up to 1440p does
quickly change the standings and now the
6T950 XT is seen matching the original
RTX3090 with 206 FPS on average and 11%
boost over the original sixtnine00 XT.
It was also just 4% faster than the
RTX3080 Ti but 7% slower than the
RTX3090 Ti though from a value
standpoint that's not a bad result for
AMD given the 6T950 XT is cheaper than
both GeForce GPUs. Then at 4K, the AMP
architecture takes over. And now even
the original 10 GB version of the RTX
380 is faster than the new 6T950 XT in
this title. And that's despite the
refresh being 11% faster than the
original sixtnine XT. Still, this is
again a good result for AMD in terms of
value. The RTX3080 Ti, for example,
might be 11% faster, but it also costs
16% more, while the RTX3090 Ti costs 82%
more for a 28% increase at 4K in this
title. Next, we have Watchdog Legion.
And again, the 6950 XT is clearly a
chart topper at 1080p, averaging 168
FPS, though that did make it just 6%
faster than the sixtyn00 XT and a mere
6% faster than what should be the much
cheaper 6800 XT, though in reality it
isn't. Even at 1440p, the Radeon GPUs
maintain a decent performance advantage
over their GeForce competitors. And here
the 6T950 XT was just 12% faster than
the RTX3090 Ti, 21% faster than the
RTX3090, and 23% faster than the RTX3080
Ti. So, those are some impressive
margins, though it was just 5% faster
than the original 6TN00 XT. Then at 4K,
the AMA based GPUs do come back quite
hard, but still the 6950 XT was able to
maintain the top spot, edging out the
RTX 3090 Ti by just a few frames. Here
we're looking at an 11% performance
boost over the sixtyn00 XT. So not a bad
result and pretty well in line with the
price hike. Moving on to Shadow of the
Tomb Raider. The 6T950 XT is again able
to command top spot at 1080p, delivering
201 FPS on average, which is an 8%
increase over the six-t.
It's also a 5% boost over the RTX3090
Ti, 12% over the RTX3090, and 13% over
the RTX3080 Ti. The margins remain much
the same at 1440p. Here, the 6t950 XT
edged out the RTX3090 Ti by a 3% margin
and boosted performance over the
sixtyn00 XT by 11%. So, a strong result
here for AMD. Of course, as usual, it's
the 4K resolution that proves to be a
real challenge for RDNA2 in its battle
with AMP here. And now, it's the RTX3090
Ti that leads the 6T950 XT by an 8%
margin. And this time we are looking at
a 12% performance boost for the 6T950 XT
over the sixtyn00 XT. And that was
enough to put it just ahead of the
RTX3090 and 3080 Ti. Now the second last
game we're going to look at is The Outer
Worlds. And here the Radeon GPUs don't
fare quite as well as evidenced by these
1080p results. The 6T950 XT was only
slightly slower than the RTX 3090 Ti,
but this is the first example we have
where it wasn't faster at 1080p. Still,
we're looking at very similar
performance between the RTX 380 Ti,
sixtynine XT, RTX3090, 6T950 XT, and
RTX3090 Ti. Now, increasing the
resolution of 1440p does reduce just how
CPUbound the Outerorlds testing is, and
now we're seeing an 8% performance
increase from the 6TN00 XT to the 6T50
XT. The RTX 390 Ti is now also 10%
faster than the 6T950 XT, though it does
cost over 80% more. So, hard to say how
much of a win that is for Nvidia.
Finally, at 4K, the 6T950 XT is now able
to match the RTX 3080 GB despite
offering a 12% boost over the six-t.
We're also looking at a situation where
the RTX 3090 Ti is now 22% faster than
the 6T950 XT. Finally, we're going to
wrap up the individual game data with a
look at F1 2021. And of course, we'll
start with the 1080p data. Again, we
find another example where the 6T950 XT
is unable to beat the RTX3090 series at
1080p. This time, trailing the 3090 Ti
by an 8% margin, though it was a little
faster than the 3080 Ti, which is
technically a good result given it is
cheaper. Increasing the resolution to
1440p sees the RTX 3080 Ti close in on
the 6T950 XT, though the margin to the
RTX3090 remains much the same, while the
3090 Ti was 8% faster. We're also
looking at a 12% increase for the 6950
XT over the sixtyn00 XT. So, about as
good as you could hope for. Finally, at
4K, the 6T950 XT falls a little further
behind the RTX 380 Ti and trails the RTX
3090 Ti by a 16% margin. And that's
despite boosting performance over the
original 6T900 XT by 13%.
All right, it's now time to look at
total system power consumption. And here
the 6T950 XT pushed total system usage
to 528 watts. And that's a massive 19%
increase in total power usage when
compared to the 6TN00 XT for what looked
like around 10% more performance. So
efficiency certainly has gone out the
window with these overclocked models. I
did think that power usage of the 3090
Ti was pretty horrible, but the 6T950 XT
is only dropping system usage by about
8%. So, if you do care about power usage
and efficiency, it probably goes without
saying, but these overclocked to the max
models won't be for you. So,
performance-wise, the Raiden RX 6950 XT
did a good job of topping those charts,
especially at the lower resolutions. Not
as competitive at 4K as you'd probably
like, but that's been the RDNA2 versus
AMP situation since the new generations
kicked off. And then of course compared
to the 6900 XT, it wasn't that
impressive. But that's sort of been the
story of this 50 series refresh. Anyway,
to get a good idea of how they stack up,
let's look at the 11 game average before
moving into our cost per frame analysis.
Starting with the 1080p average data, we
see that for low resolution gamers
targeting maximum FPS, so I imagine
mostly competitive shooter type gamers,
the Radeon RX6950 XT is about as good as
it gets for out of the box performance.
That said, we are only talking about a
3% boost over the RTX3090 Ti, but it's
around 45% cheaper. So, a clear win
there for AMD. When compared to the
sixtyn00 XT, though, we're only looking
at a 6% boost. So, certainly not worth
the premium. Now, at 1440p, the 6950 XT
and RTX 390 Ti are neck andneck with 149
FPS on average across the 11 games
tested. And that means a 9% performance
boost for the 6950 XT over the six00 XT
and an 11% increase over the more
expensive RTX 3080 Ti. Then at 4K, the
RTX3090 Ti takes over as we've seen time
and time again, beating the 6T950 XT by
a 7% margin. Still, the 6950 XT was just
able to edge out the RTX3090 and 3080 Ti
with a 12% boost over the original
sixt900 XT. Okay, so again, I'm going to
start out our cost per frame analysis
with the mythical MSRP, as many of you
are still interested in this data, it
seems, even if it's not relevant to the
current market. Anyway, had these GPUs
been available at their MSRP, this is
how the RDNA2 and AMP generations would
have stacked up at the high end using
our 1440p data. Basically for the
sensible options, let's say so the
Radeon RX6800 XT and GeForce RTX 380 10
GB AMD and Nvidia would have been very
evenly matched in terms of performance
and value. A slight premium for the
RTX3080 can be seen, but that product
probably does justify commanding a
slight premium. Now, where the value
goes completely out the window is with
the AMD and Nvidia refresh products and
of course the Halo versions. For
rasterization performance, the 6900 XT
is much better value than the RTX3090,
saving you around 28% per frame. But for
high resolution gaming, the RTX3090 is
the faster Halo product with better
features, making it the better dumb
product, as we like to put it.
Interestingly, at the MSRP, the 6950 XT
is slightly better value than the
original model, dropping the cost per
frame by about 2%. So, they're basically
the same in terms of value at the MSRP.
The RTX 390 Ti cost 70% more per frame
than the 6950 XT based on the MSRP. So,
I'm not sure what to say about that one
really. So, let's just move on to the
real world pricing. Right. So, here's a
really good reality check at the high
end. The 6950 XT has been listed at the
MSRP at retailers, and that makes sense
given the 6T900 XT is selling for just
below the MSRP as we found multiple
models available for $950 US. Quite
surprisingly though, the 6800 XT is
still up around $860,
which is a 76% price increase from the
6700 XT when in reality it should be
more like 35%. So keep that in mind as I
will discuss this further towards the
end of the video. As it stands, AMD's
high-end lineup is in line with Nvidia's
sensible high-end options, so the RTX
380 10 GB. we see that pricing for the
GeForce GPUs gets completely ridiculous
once we reach the RTX 380 Ti and beyond.
From the 6950 XT, the cost per frame
jumps up by 24% for the RTX3080 Ti and
then 70% for the RTX3090 and 3090 Ti.
So, if you had $1,000 US or more to
spend on a high-end GPU, but you weren't
into getting uh let's say shafted, then
you'd go with the six00 XT or maybe the
6T950 XT as it's only 4% more per frame.
Now, let's take a look at the thermal
and clock characteristics of the MSI and
Sapphire 6950 XT graphics cards that we
have on hand for testing. Starting with
the 6T950 XT Gaming X Trio, we have a
typical looking card from MSI. I'd
summarize it as a quality but basic
design. A triple slot, triple fan card
with the typical Gaming X Trio looks.
Performance-wise, it saw a peak GPU
temperature of 77° when installed inside
a Corser Obsidian 500D test case with a
room temperature of 21°. So, a good
result given the power consumption of
the 6T950 XT GPU. The fans though did
spin at 2,000 RPM to maintain that
temperature and could be just heard over
our case fans. So, a relatively quiet
high-end graphics card then. The cores
typically clocked at 2,470 MHz with GPU
power around 332 W. Now, the massive
Sapphire 6950 XT Nitro Plus Pure is a
triple fan four slot monster. And in my
opinion, this card looks amazing. Now,
this model does feature dual BIOS
support, which in my opinion is
essential for any graphics card priced
over $300 US. Certainly over $400 US,
which is why it's disappointing that MSI
has omitted this feature. Thankfully,
the Nitro Plus Pure doesn't though, and
out of the box using the primary mode,
this is how the card behaves. The GPU
peaked at 76° with a fan speed of just
1,200 RPM, making it noticeably quieter
than the MSI model. That said, it did
clock slightly lower at 2350 MHz. So, a
5% reduction there, but this is the
primary or standard operating BIOS. So,
switching to the OC BIOS actually saw
the peak GPU temperature decline ever so
slightly as the fan speed increased
to,400 RPM. But even here, the Nitro
Plus Pure couldn't be heard over our
case fans. The GPU clock speed now
averages 2,430 MHz. So, a similar clock
frequency to that of the Gaming X Trio
at a lower operating volume and
temperature. So, a great result for this
Sapphire graphics card. And I've got to
say, I love the Nitro Plus Pure. And
this thing will be moving into my
editing PC. So, despite the Gaming Xray
branding, this MSI model is quite basic
and omits crucial features such as dual
BOS support, for example. So, that was
disappointing to see. The Sapphire 6T950
XT Nitro Plus Pure is a much more
impressive looking graphics card in my
opinion that's also significantly
larger, taking up four slots. It's
really just a beast of a thing. It also
costs $200 more at $1,300 US. But if
you're interested in a 6950 XT, then I
feel these higherend models make a bit
more sense as it's sort of a go big or
go home type situation with these Halo
products. Anyway, both are excellent
graphics cards that represent the 6T950
XT well, but damn does the Nitro Plus
Pure look good in my editing PC. All
right, so let's start to wrap things up
with the the positive stuff. We'll start
on a positive note, and that being that
the MSI and Sapphire 6950 XT graphics
cards are excellent. the MSI Gaming XRO.
It is a more of a basic graphics card,
let's say, despite the fact that it is
relatively large. You know, triple slot,
triple fan design, and under full load,
it did keep the GPU temperatures below
80° with a reasonable fan speed of
around 2,000 RPM. And that did make it
relatively cool and quiet. And of
course, it is available at the MSRP.
Now, let's focus specifically on the
Radeon RX6950
XT. There are a few ways to view this
release. As a chart topper, it does well
against the RTX3090 Ti at a dramatically
lower price point. So, in that sense, it
does a great job and is an excellent
competitor. It's also not bad in terms
of value next to the original sixtyn00
XT. And with value less of a concern,
let's say for a flagship product, I
don't have too much of an issue with it.
And it's really a bit difficult to go
hard on AMD for raising prices given how
much cheaper Radeon GPUs are than their
GeForce competitors. Of course, AMD
would love you to pay more, but they
simply don't have the mind share and
brand reputation to get away with the
same absurd prices that Nvidia can. So,
they're not intentionally doing gamers a
favor. It just works out kind of nice
for consumers that don't have eyes just
for the green team. But where this sort
of thing annoys me, and I can see
through the corporate greed, unlike
certain fans of certain brands, is the
market manipulation. Of course, supply
and demand dictates prices, but with
multiple products sharing the same
silicon, it is possible to caress the
market towards greater profit margins,
and this is something we've gone after
Nvidia for several times this generation
alone. So, it would be unfair not to
call AMD out for doing the same. You
see, as I noted in our cost per frame
analysis, the RX6800
is meant to cost 21% more than the 6700
XT, while the 6800 XT is meant to cost
35% more. However, in reality, the
RX6800 costs 55% more, while the 6800 XT
costs 76% more. And the reason for this
being that the 6800 and 6700 series use
completely different silicon while the
6800 and 6900 series share the same
silicon. So you see what AMD is doing.
rather than sell you their 520 mm square
Na'vi 21 silicon for around $590, which
is where the RX6800 should be, they're
limiting supply of the 6800 series,
which increases the price, pushing the
6800 up to $760.
And in turn, this makes their sixtine
series appear much more reasonable,
offering a similar cost per frame at
over $900. But why stop there? They can
and well they have gone a step further
with the 6T950 XT to make an additional
$100 US per unit sold. And while it is
possible for AMD to get away with doing
this, you can still expect 6800 6800 XT
and I suspect even the six00 XT supply
to be very limited. So I'm certainly not
a fan of this somewhat artificial
inflation of GPU pricing. But while
gamers continue to purchase products
like the RTX3090 and RX6900 series, AMD
and Nvidia will continue to divert as
much supply as possible to those premium
models. Anyway, that is going to do it
for this video. Hope you enjoyed this
look at the 6950 XT and if you agree
with well our take on these cards, then
let us know in the comment section
below. If you think the 6950 XT is a
good thing, uh let me know why you think
that in the comment section below. I'll
be interested to read your thoughts as
always. But yeah, that is going to do it
for this one. Uh, if you'd like to
support the channel directly, we have
float plane Patreon. You've got access
to our exclusive Discord server, monthly
live stream that'll be coming up
shortly. Q& A's, behind the scenes
content, a lot of cool stuff there. So,
if you're interested, check it out. But
if not, perfectly fine. And I would like
to just thank you for watching this
video. I'm your host, Steve, and I'll
see you again next time.
[Music]